it's good old teargas friendly right
control weapon the most commonly used
tear gas is made up of a chemical
compound called CS a white solid powder
mixed with aerosol when sprayed its
effects are immediate burning eyes
difficulty breathing and the skin that
feels like it's on fire tear gases
effects usually go away after several
hours but in rare places tear gas can be
lethal it's a chemical weapon that's
actually banned in warfare by most
countries including the United States so
what's the catch the use of tear gas to
disperse crowds is legal which is why
you've seen it used on protestors
worldwide and guess what since January
tear gas has been deployed in the
northern 40 countries and most of the
tear gas used around the world is new in
the USA by these all American companies